i
[Música]
buenas noches a todos sé que no están
tristes porque porque todavía falta más
bien creo que están muy contentos porque
soy la última ellas se pueden ir a
descansar
bueno
hoy como humanidad vivimos digamos una
crisis planetaria que afecta de manera
muy profunda sin precedentes en la
historia a todo el mundo y eso no lo
digo yo solamente lo dice también sin
duda y esta es una noticia y una nota
hoy del banco mundial esta crisis
planetaria está en todos los ámbitos de
nuestra vida y sin duda una de las
manifestaciones más claras y concretas
de esta crisis es la violencia la
violencia que está tocando todos los
días a nuestra puerta cada vez de una
manera más cercana cada vez de una
manera más intensa y más fuerte el cb
children pensamos que esta crisis
planetaria se tiene que detener que
todos tenemos que hacer un esfuerzo por
lograr terminar con ella y una de las
formas que nosotros
que es importante en ese sentido tiene
que ver sin duda con resignificar el
sentido y el concepto de nosotros
nuestra cultura es una cultura que
promueve la discriminación
tradicionalmente que promueve la
distinción personal que discrimina que
nos generan competencia y que reproduce
el individualismo entonces a qué nos
referimos con el concepto de nosotros
nos referimos a una idea que hoy
escuchamos mucho en la tarde que tiene
que ver con la idea de colectividad con
la idea de pensar que si a cada uno de
ustedes les va bien o a ti te va bien a
todos nos va a ir bien tiene que ver con
esta idea fundamental también de que
somos una parte pequeña de algo muy
grande en la humanidad que solo se
mantendrá si somos capaces de verdad de
actuar por el bien común
esta pérdida de nosotros es una pérdida
que va a tener de verdad implicaciones
muy grandes en nuestra sociedad
en este momento presente y en los
próximos 20 años y sin duda a quien para
quien va a tener más efectos es en los
niños y las niñas esta crisis planetaria
decíamos se manifiesta en todos los
ámbitos de la sociedad se manifiesta
digamos a nivel político y económico
estamos hablando de un momento en donde
hay digamos una gran inestabilidad
económica hay crisis financiera en
muchos de los mercados se han exacerbado
las condiciones de desigualdad hay sin
duda un gran una gran cantidad de
desempleo y por supuesto cada vez más
hay trabajos más pauperizados más pobres
pero sobre todo también enfrenta una
crisis de legitimidad los gobiernos
hoy como nunca esto se demuestra digamos
en la américa latina que vive hoy una
américa latina convulsa en donde nos
encontramos grandes movimientos en
colombia en nicaragua en chile en
venezuela y por supuesto en mexico
otro ámbito digamos que refleja esta
crisis planetaria tiene que ver con algo
que está en el tema y en el ambiente de
manera muy importante y es precisamente
la crisis que se refleja en el medio
ambiente y bueno estamos conscientes de
que estamos enfrentando escasez de agua
procesos de desertificación agotamiento
de recursos naturales que cada vez más
hay fenómenos naturales que afectan a
las personas y por supuesto están
haciendo la extinción de las especies y
sin duda este es un fenómeno del
calentamiento global y del cambio
climático y es otro elemento crítico de
esta crisis planetaria a la que me
refiero
pero yo quisiera profundizar hoy a la
que se refiere al nivel civilizatorio en
donde experimentamos por supuesto la
polarización las diferencias el
agudizamiento de la discriminación lo
que se refleja muy claramente incluso la
violencia en las redes sociales y bueno
por supuesto el incremento del crimen
organizado y decíamos la normalización
de la violencia
estas situaciones están todas
interrelacionadas porque se refieren
finalmente a un sistema es el efecto
mariposa lo que sucede en un ámbito
afecta a todos los demás y agudiza esas
condiciones de la crisis de nuestra
sociedad por eso quisiera que hoy en
estos minutos últimos y espero que no
con mucho cansancio
y podamos reflexionar un poco sobre lo
que implica esta violencia esta
situación civilizatoria de violencia a
la que estamos sometidos como sociedad y
sin duda como mexicanos y mexicanos y
desde luego también en específicamente
las implicaciones que tiene por razones
obvias llegamos en relación a la
institución que yo represento a save the
children y las implicaciones que tiene
particularmente para los niños y las
niñas la violencia ha sido digamos
clasificada y determinada por filósofos
y social y sociólogos como un fenómeno
que tiene que es el resultado de
consecuencias en realidad para ser
children la violencia es también una
causa y también una consecuencia
es causa cuando partimos de la base de
que estamos hablando de una sociedad que
tiene una perspectiva patriarcal es
decir está basada en un modelo que gira
alrededor digamos de la dominación de la
explotación y del control y del poder de
uno sobre otros que eso es lo que
permite finalmente perpetuar el sistema
la violencia también es causa porque se
reproduce en los canales que legitimamos
como patrones culturales
entonces se desarrolla en la familia en
la escuela y en todos los espacios donde
aprendemos a hacer y a formar parte de
la sociedad la violencia y sus diversas
manifestaciones parte de patrones de
crianza que condiciona la pertenencia
origina la discriminación justifican y
legitiman la dominación
y bueno las diversas manifestaciones de
violencia utilizan el castigo físico y
psicológico como un trato que es
verdaderamente humillante para hacer de
esto un mecanismo correctivo de
educación y de formación de los niños y
las niñas sin tomar en cuenta finalmente
todo lo que esto afecta a su desarrollo
ya su salud mental la violencia es
también una consecuencia cuando el
sistema no resuelve las necesidades
físicas económicas espirituales y
emocionales de las personas y por eso se
habla de una violencia como una causa y
una manifestación estructural porque
afecta a todas las clases sociales y por
supuesto a una gran cantidad de
sociedades y también y esta es otra
consecuencia es el resultado de un
modelaje en donde transmitimos de una
manera inconsciente muchas de las
actitudes individuales y sociales
están en ese entorno que finalmente es
un entorno de estrés tóxico en donde por
qué estamos al que nosotros estamos
expuestos en lo cotidiano y que por
supuesto también compartimos con los
niños y las niñas
esta violencia es una violencia tan
generalizada en todos los ámbitos de
nuestra vida que se invisibiliza y se
considera como algo normal
tan normal como dar una nalgada a un
niño o golpearlo para que se le quite lo
rebelde
tan normal para que finalmente los niños
sean clasificados y valorados en una
escuela lo que finalmente también es un
efecto discriminatorio tan normal que
bueno los padres de familia tienden a
ver a generar expectativas en la vida de
sus hijos como si fueran la suya en vez
de pensar que pueden dejarlo ser esa es
una visión normal de la vida esta hay
muchas otras que generan sin duda
situaciones de violencia una violencia
que no es tan grave pero que también
genera una circunstancia enorme de
someter de sometimiento de dominación y
de control
así en nuestro día a día nos vamos
acostumbrando a un ambiente que está
constantemente promoviendo la violencia
y que causa enormes estragos en la vida
de los niños y las niñas porque hasta
ahorita hemos hablado de una violencia
común
pero qué pasa cuando oímos estas cosas
laura
fue violada a los 13 años hoy tiene un
bebé
ella quiere regresar a la escuela
y su comunidad escolar y su familia no
la dejan porque el aura hoy es un mal
ejemplo para su hermana y para las otras
chicas de la escuela antonio de 11 años
salió la semana pasada de un hospital
llegó con lesiones graves lo golpearon
en su casa
antonio nunca más estará seguro en su
hogar sandra a sus 15 años tuvo que
esconderse en una plaza comercial y
quedarse pecho a tierra seis horas
mientras el narco tomaba las calles en
culiacán sinaloa
jessica de guatemala con tan sólo cuatro
años llegó a la frontera y ahí con su
padre fue finalmente separada de su
padre y mandada a una casa en nueva york
a una casa hogar durante durante seis
meses sufriendo terribles condiciones de
maltrato y de violencia
gracias a una gestión de save the
children de mucho trabajo logramos
cuando menos en este caso la
reunificación familiar
el caso del aura de antonio de sandra de
jessica y de miles de niños y niñas se
repiten todos los días son tan comunes
ya que se vuelven invisibles lo que no
significa que sean crueles digamos cómo
podemos cómo podemos dejar de pensar que
la violencia sobre los niños y las niñas
no existe solo habría que recordar que
en el 2018 más de 2300 niños en méxico
fueron asesinados la estadística nos
habla de que hoy cada día cuatro niños y
niñas mueren una cifra que supera las
zonas de conflicto armado como siria
como poder no recordar que el 30 por
ciento de los niños de este país en
estudios recientes lo que estamos
hablando de 28 millones de niñas y niños
lo que es reciben como proceso educativo
es un castigo físico y un castigo
humillante la violencia que viven los
niños y las niñas debe hacerse visible y
no es tan difícil detectarla si en
verdad nosotros tenemos la conciencia y
la capacidad de observar lo que están
viviendo los niños y las niñas de
nuestro país hay muchísimos muchísimos
elementos que nos permiten efectivamente
detectar esto a nivel físico pues los
niños y las niñas que están sometidos a
situaciones de violencia tienen dolores
de cabeza tienen problemas
gastrointestinales tienen incontinencia
urinaria la verdad que desarrollan
diversas formas de de somatización e
incluso por supuesto reportan pesadillas
terrores nocturnos etcétera a nivel
cognitivo encontramos niños y niñas que
tienen problemas de atención de
retención e incluso de memoria a nivel
emocional muestran hiperactividad hoy el
gran fenómeno de los niños y las niñas
una gran cantidad
de niños y niñas hiperactivos presentan
miedo hostilidad agresividad ansiedad
angustia retraimiento trastornos
depresivos o sea que los elementos para
detectar los problemas están qué pasa
con los niños y niñas que presentan
estas condiciones en su vida cotidiana
son niños y niñas que tienen una baja
auto valoración de sí mismos que
presentan ausentismo escolar que tienen
apatía que son agresivos que tienen una
propensión a decir mentiras hacer
trampas que desarrollan conductas
adictivas a la comida al alcohol a las
drogas que se sexual izan muy pronto en
sus actitudes que tienen sexo prematuro
que se hacen daño auto infligido que
tienen tendencias suicidas incluso y que
por supuesto les resulta muy difícil
internalizar las normas que los han
hecho toma
cuando el mundo adulto percibe a estos
niños y estas niñas con estos síntomas
lo usual es que los estigmatiza generan
juicios los califican son los niños
conflictivos son los niños problemas son
los que finalmente generan conflictos en
la interacción social y bueno esto a la
larga lo que le genera a estos niños ya
estas niñas es más presión más estrés
más depresión y vuelven a estar
revictimizados
en la mayor parte de los casos
tristemente no esto estos estos niños y
estas niñas no reciben una atención
adecuada
mucho menos que en casos todavía graves
por lo menos son denunciados con las
autoridades al no tener digamos un
abordaje adecuado de atención al no
encontrar una salida de recuperación las
heridas que tienen estos niños y estas
niñas finalmente se recrudecen se
vuelven odio se vuelven resentimiento la
verdad es que resulta muy difícil no en
verdad poder pensar que si con las
condiciones de cariño y de afecto puedan
tener un mecanismo de resiliencia y
sanación en realidad si el tema sí sí sí
al contrario los niños son atendidos y
son tratados adecuadamente las personas
y sobre todo niños y niñas con su
capacidad de resiliencia se conectan con
la sanación se vuelven empáticos
compasivos y sus procesos de
recuperación en verdad son un ejemplo de
lo que de la esperanza y de las
posibilidades que todavía tenemos como
sociedad
qué podemos hacer para revertir esta
situación como dejamos aquí al de aquí a
los 20 años un legado distinto para los
niños y las niñas del mundo bueno para
servir children digamos lo que ha sido
importante es reconocer que tenemos que
tener formas distintas de relación y un
acercamiento distinto a la realidad hoy
pensamos que uno de los temas
fundamentales es consolidar la identidad
de los niños asumirlos como lo que son
hoy decía danger algo muy importante y
esa es la filosofía de severin aceptar a
los niños ya las niñas como lo que son y
con lo que viene reconocer que son seres
humanos legítimos por el solo hecho de
existir que son valiosos y que tienen
que ser recibidos en la vida y en la
sociedad con lo que ellos tienen que
aportar necesitamos también impulsar un
desarrollo holístico
los retos inéditos que van a enfrentar
estos niños y niñas ante la crisis y los
distintos ámbitos que he descrito son
enormes por eso necesitamos sin duda que
los niños desarrollen su potencial
físico intelectual emocional y
espiritual esto pasa por un trabajo
cotidiano esta pasa por una acción de
activismo esto pasa por un proceso en
donde les damos herramientas a padres de
familia a los maestros y a los adultos
para que efectivamente puedan comprender
acompañar contener y orientar a los
niños ya las niñas en cada una de las
etapas de su vida generando desde luego
sus posibilidades de desarrollo de
protección de participación y de
sobrevivencia otro aspecto que nosotros
consideramos importantísimo es sin duda
generar e impulsar una cultura de paz
promoviendo pautas de crianza con
ternura entre las familias y un trato
sensible y cariñoso
todos los sectores en donde un niño y
una niña interactúa en la escuela en el
hospital en la comunidad en el espacio y
eso parte de la decisión de nosotros
como adultos para hacerlo lograr también
y se sería un tercer aspecto que los
adultos de verdad cambien su paradigma
con los niños y las niñas lo respeten
los vean como sujetos de derechos y
participen y les den la posibilidad
también de participar activa y
respetuosamente a los niños y las niñas
y por último consideramos importantísimo
promover que los niños y las niñas
tengan un espacio propio experiencias de
save the children en condiciones y
entornos de violencia y de muchas otras
organizaciones hay muchos la adversidad
y los desafíos que los niños y las niñas
enfrentan en esos entornos en su vida
cotidiana son severos pero cuando se
crean estos espacios la creatividad
y la posibilidad lúdica la relación e
interacción entre niños y niñas entre
iguales y pares con una visión de
justicia de dignidad y de igualdad de
verdad hacen creer que en esta crisis
civilizatoria hay esperanza estas son
digamos las acciones básicas del piso
mínimo con el que podemos empezar y
parte de la base de que cada uno de
ustedes cada uno de nosotros hoy después
de una tarde tan creativa con tanto
talento con tanto compromiso con tantos
mensajes no olvidan uno que tenemos que
resignificar de verdad nuestro papel
como seres humanos que tenemos que de
nuevo en verdad reconstruir y restaurar
el concepto de antaño sobre nosotros
nosotros somos corresponsables de este
cambio de la sociedad tengamos esperanza
tengamos fe tengamos ánimo para lograrlo
y actuemos también en consecuencia
cambiando desde hoy la forma en la que
vemos y tratamos a los niños ya las
niñas la forma en la que vemos y
tratamos a otros adultos la forma en la
que vemos y tratamos a las mujeres como
elemento clave de nuestra sociedad
yo termino con esto estoy muy agradecida
de verdad de que me hayan permitido en
estar un espacio tan joven tan creativo
tan lleno de talento tan lleno de
compromiso me siento muy honrada en
verdad por haber estado con ustedes el
día de hoy y solo quiero cerrar con un
vídeo en donde una pequeña una niña
llamada 'la u' me quiere y puede ser
libre y ser feliz muchas gracias a todos
ya todas buenas noches
[Aplausos]